usually have their id next to the things  that they do payment with once they have  given you the id because it's much  easier to ask someone for their id then  it just asks them for their payment  method you then say awesome you see it  you take a picture of it if it's on zoom  because you need it for your stuff or if  you're in person you should take it from  them and the reason you do this is  because it actually builds trust when  you give it back right because it means  that like hey you have nothing to fear  here i grabbed it from you and i'm  giving it back but it's much easier to  grab someone's id than to describe  someone's credit card